you begin with the conviction of Elaine
Maxwell for being part of Jeffrey
Epstein's sex abuse ring Maxwell was
found guilty on five out of six counts
including sex trafficking of a minor
four accusers testified during the trial
that Maxwell and Epstein worked together
to abuse them along with other girls as
young as 14 years old between 1994 and
2004. Maxwell denies the allegations
drika Duncan is outside the federal
courthouse in lower Manhattan where the
verdict came in yesterday jerika for
victims this has been a long time coming
it really has Jamie and what makes this
case so different from other
high-profile sexual abuse cases we've
covered is this one involved a woman
that was directly connected to the abuse
of girls young girls now throughout this
trial we heard gut-wrenching testimony
from those accusers meanwhile Maxwell's
attorneys maintained that she was simply
a scapegoat but the jurors saw this
differently and now Maxwell who just
turned 60 on Christmas Day is facing the
rest of her life Behind Bars
galane Maxwell said in her chair with
little emotion only pouring herself a
glass of water as the judge read the
verdict guilty on all but one count
after some 40 hours of deliberations the
jury convicted Maxwell on five charges
including sex trafficking a minor for
Jeffrey Epstein and three counts of
conspiracy related to his sex abuse ring
Maxwell was found not guilty on account
of enticement during the month-long
trial four accusers described in graphic
detail Maxwell's role in sex trafficking
girls for Jeffrey Epstein one victim
Carolyn said that at 14 years old she
was paid hundreds of dollars to visit
Epstein several times a week and to
perform sexualized massages from 2001 to
2004 and Annie farmer told the court
Maxwell also participated in the abuse
saying that Maxwell offered to give her
a massage and allegedly fondled her
breasts farmer the only one to testify
under her real name said in a statement
after the verdict I hope that this
verdict brings Solace to all who need it
and demonstrates that no one is above
the law this is a great day for the
justices
attorney David boyes represents farmer
and several other survivors everybody
failed them except themselves
they stood up for themselves and they
wouldn't be silenced Maxwell didn't
testify during the trial telling the
judge the government has not proven its
case Beyond A Reasonable Doubt and so
there is no need for me to testify we
are very disappointed with the verdict
we have already started working on the
appeal and we are confident that she
will be Vindicated Virginia dufre one of
Epstein's accusers who was not part of
this case said yesterday that Maxwell
did not act alone to Frey alleges she
was trafficked to prince Andrew when she
was 17. she's suing the prince in a
civil suit he has denied you phrase
claims and says he doesn't recall ever
meeting her Epstein and Maxwell
could not
have acted did not act alone
they could not have had the sex
trafficking operation that they had of
the scope and scale spanning five
continents lasting decades without the
wealthy powerful collaborators that they
had and those people need to be brought
to justice as well
now a sentencing date has not been said
but Maxwell faces a maximum of 65 years
in prison and when you look at this
story as a whole it is not over next
week a judge will hear a motion from the
defense team for prince Andrew why he is
trying to get that civil case dismissed
against him Jamie
some ways it's only just beginning
darika thank you our cover